pode ser até o final dessa palestra
vocês não lembra meu nome mas sem dúvida
vocês vão lembrar da seguinte frase não
corra atrás curta na frente essa frase
ela pode ter vários tipos de
interpretações mas sem dúvidas por
menino pobre preto de favela que saiu a
como desde criança colocou na cabeça que
necessariamente Precisava mudar de vida
essa frase de muita coisa sabe o remo
Então sai do Bolt que para Eles venceram
nos esportes de precisão chegar na
frente é um pouco sobre isso e aqui não
necessariamente é sobre Vencer é sobre
estratégia é sobre comunicação é sobre
inteligência emocional sobre ambição
essa ambição que durante 500 anos
tentaram cheirar é um pouco do que eu
tenho que imprimir na minha vida é um
pouco do que eu tenho que levar para os
meus prazer meu nome é Jara eu sou
advogado formado pela UERJ uma das
melhores faculdades de direito no Brasil
eu tive oportunidade de duas vezes e
mora fora do país da vg lugares do mundo
passei pelas principais multinacionais
no ramo de cerveja de bebida e
atualmente Eu trabalho no maior banco
digital do mundo como especialista de
inclusão diversidade de fato a minha
rotina é extremamente pesada mas mesmo
tendo uma rotina extremamente corrida eu
não satisfeito de fazer pouca coisa eu
arrumei espaço para fundar um instituto
de quiosque que tem como objetivo
principal objetivo final da suporte na
carreira de pessoas negras
Porque tem uma frase que eu acho que ela
desconecta muito com isso e ela é falada
pelo Emicida que viver é partir voltar
de repartir e o É exatamente sobre isso
exatamente voltar e repartir o que que
eu falo voluntário repartir por que na
minha infância na adolescência eu não
tive algumas oportunidades que hoje
através do eu procuro proporcionar e
criar outras pessoas eu sou filho de uma
mãe e com menos de 30 anos já tinha
quatro filhos a nossa infância foi
extremamente difícil para você ter
relação com 12 anos eu costumo dizer que
eu tive o primeiro empreendimento eu era
essas crianças que ficava nas ruas nos
sinais e vendendo bala vendendo jornal
vendendo refrigerante
E foi exatamente com 12 anos que talvez
eu tenha tomado meu primeiro soco no
estômago
eu lembro claramente tá muito vivo na
minha mente eu tava na Lagoa Rodrigo de
Freitas para quem conhece a Lagoa
Rodrigo de Freitas 1 bairro super nobre
do Rio de Janeiro eu tava parado no
sinal do lado direito tem um clube do
Flamengo na minha frente de uma máquina
chamada melô e por volta das 5:30 às 6
horas começaram a sair vários
adolescente de 11 12 13 anos e eu fiquei
preso naquela imagem porque eu comecei a
ver que eles estavam dentro de um
ambiente se divertindo e eu comecei a me
questionar porque ele e não eu o que que
eles tinham que eu não tinha o que que
eles tiveram que eu não tive e
obviamente
passado se o tempo eu entendi que tudo
aquilo era fruto de igualdade social
racismo estrutural Mas aquela imagem
Ficou claro na minha cabeça na verdade
aquela imagem da Claro na minha cabeça
até hoje o tempo passou com 14 anos
infelizmente a minha mãe ficou doente eu
tive que ir morar com a minha vó e
também foi o momento que eu tive que
tomar minha vida porque quando a minha
mãe melhorou eu simplesmente Decidi não
voltar a morar com a minha mãe porque
naquele contexto com a minha vó eu não
passava algumas dificuldades alguns
perrengues que por exemplo eu passava
com a minha mãe e aqui a gente tá
falando de fome gente é duro falar isso
eu tenho certeza que minha mãe não
gostaria de tá ouvindo isso mais aqui
estou falando de fome mas do outro lado
eu lembro que aquela imagem quando eu
tinha 12 anos que ficou na minha cabeça
e quando eu vi aquelas crianças eu tive
vontade de ter o que ela que aquelas
crianças estavam tendo e confesso que
geral até uma certa inveja só que aquela
missão que nasce em mim quando eu tinha
12 anos quando eu fiz 14 anos morando
com a minha avó eu botei realizei ela
então pelas ruas do Rio de Janeiro bate
praticamente todas as escolas
particulares do Rio de Janeiro pedindo
bolsa e obviamente você imagina menino
pretinho na frente de uma escola
particular de classe média alta de
escola que ele chega perto mas eu
consegui bolsa e uma dessas escolas
comecei a conviver com outras pessoas
disse que o seu tamanho diferente e foi
exatamente aí que um pouco da minha
referência foi mudando os meus amigos
passaram a ser um pouco da minha
referência então quando Eles resolveram
fazer vestibular porque eu queria fazer
vestibular mas eu não sabia como eu
passei a querer fazer vestibular mas a
minha mãe da educação não tinha sido uma
das melhores então eu acabei não
passando fiquei um ano depois de
conseguir uma outra bolsa no melhor
curso pré-vestibular do Rio de Janeiro
uma anja chamada Andréia Acabou me
ajudando e o Curioso que eu passei
praticamente um ano que horas da manhã
cedo 10 horas da noite desse cursinho
pré-vestibular porque eu tava tão focado
em passar no vestibular porque eu sabia
que ele era alavanca de mudar de vida
que em vários momentos da eu entrar às 7
horas e sair 10 horas da noite e várias
vezes eu ficava sem almoçar porque
também muitas vezes eu não tinha
dinheiro acabei passando em vários
vestibulares
escolhi fazer direito a melhor faculdade
de direito na época do Brasil que é UERJ
e quando eu entrei na UERJ talvez tenha
sido o primeiro momento em que o Igor
ele concedeu dentro de mim por quê
Porque eu vi pessoas negras dentro de
uma estrutura de uma faculdade pública
que já com cotas e que não tinha os
mesmos Espaços das pessoas brancas fazer
direito na UERJ é um ambiente
extremamente elitista é um curso super
difícil e naquele contexto a gente tava
praticando a manutenção de alguns
estereótipos e o Curioso que quando eu
olhava para os meus amigos todos eles
tinham toda a base estrutura já né Eu
não eu já já vai de manhã eu fazia
faculdade de noite e no final de semana
eu trabalhava então eu trabalho como
garçom eu trabalhei para mudar também
comecei a blusa de festa eu sempre
procuro lembrar de andar minha
trajetória o porquê que eu não está Java
nos escritórios privados o porquê que eu
sempre preferia fazer outras coisas do
que propriamente dito e que dentro da
carreira do direito está geando
trabalhando em órgão público e aí me vem
na cabeça quantidade de vezes que eu
tentava
estágios que eu tentava estagiar no
escritório que eu tentava e para uma
empresa e eu não conseguia 1 2 3 10 20
30 vezes foram as vezes que eu tentei
arrumar estágio eu não consegui aí uma
vez
e foi um momento fatídico eu lembro que
eu passei na primeira Na segunda e na
terceira etapa e quando chegou na final
e aqui é importante para lá que várias
vezes aconteceram isso nas etapas em que
eu não tava presencial eu passava nas
etapas presenciais eu não passava mas
dessa vez ficou marcado na minha cabeça
porque era eu e mais uma pessoa e o na
época os sócios entrevistando a gente
eu pude perceber que
eu saí daquela entrevista com certeza
que eu tinha passado eu saí daquela
entrevista com certeza que aquela vaga
para mim até porque a pessoa que tava
comigo ela não só não respondeu às
perguntas como ela chorou copiosamente
todo momento da entrevista
dias depois eu recebo a ligação com a
informação que eu não tinha passado e
tempo depois conversando com um amigo
que tinha me indicado a resposta foi que
eu não tinha perfil que eu tenho mais
cara de modelo do que advogado e aí a
gente sabe que tudo isso representa
para me informar já tinha de vestido de
direito porque para mim aquilo ali tinha
sido a gota d'água e eu já tava
trabalhando com evento fazendo festa só
queria me informar e sair daquele mundo
foi quando apareceu
esse tal de caçador de talentos na minha
frente desse dizendo Radiante ele falou
que ia me colocar dentro de um processo
seletivo e que se eu passasse nesse
processo seletivo eu ganhar ia um
salário de 34 r$ 1000 na boa eu olhei
para ele e falei vem cá nunca me deram
nada nessa vida
nunca sequer me oferecer alguma coisa do
nada vai aparecer você na minha frente
para falar para mim colocar no processo
seletivo E se eu passar nesse processo
seletivo eu vou ganhar um salário de 34
reais mas aí não até porque ele falou
que era Red Hut não sabia nem que que
adianta sabia nem que queira headhunter
Um Dia Depois eu recebo ligação da
pessoa fala Oi Ana tudo bem tudo bem Ah
eu tô chamando para seletivo primeira
coisa que eu perguntei eu não já era até
porque vamos para onde é que tem no
Brasil né que está no Rio de Janeiro ela
falou aí eu amo já era eu falei para o
cidade seu Resumindo comecei a
participar do processo seletivo passei
na primeira na segunda na terceira etapa
que foi curioso que a medida que tu
passou nas etapas eu fui me sentindo
cada vez mais pertencente aquele lugar
mas com todos os medos de estar naquele
lugar porque até aquele momento eu não
me viu naquele lugar até aquele momento
eu tinha entendido que aquele lugar não
era para mim
porque historicamente aquele lugar não
foi construído para mim eu percebi que
de fato eu poderia
estar naquele lugar quando eu cheguei na
etapa do Case eu olhei para o lado e
para o outro e vi que aquelas pessoas
estavam competindo comigo não era tão
melhores do que eu como me fizeram
entender eu não passei Eu não passei só
que eu comecei a aplicar para outras
empresas que quando esse mesmo região
indicou para o outro passar seletivo e
nesse processo seletivo eu acabei
passando com processo seletivo de
Trainee mais difícil do Brasil na época
se inscreveram 85 mil pessoas e passaram
14 e eu fui uma dessas 14 pessoas e foi
também exatamente nesse momento de
entrada que eu fiquei com muito mais
força com tema de inclusão diversidade
porque porque eu fui o único treinamento
Daquela turma
e dentro do contexto que eu tava que eu
comecei a conversar com as pessoas
comecei a falar com as pessoas eu sou
uma pessoa que fala bastante eu percebi
que outras pessoas negras que tava
olhando aquela situação dentro daquela
empresa tinham algumas coisas
encarregada então eu comecei movimentado
aqui cria grupo de afinidade liderei
grupo de afinidade comecei a participar
da estratégia de inclusão diversidade
focado nas portas jateada dentro daquela
empresa que eu tava e foi também
exatamente aqui nesse momento que se tem
12 anos de idade ambição estilo de
dentro de mim se quando eu entrei na
faculdade ele praticamente nasceu quando
eu entrei na empresa
ele foi colocado na rua eu comecei fazer
mentoria com alguns jovens negros de
comunidade simplesmente que eu queria
dividir um pouco da minha experiência de
como é que está dentro do mundo
corporativo de como é você trabalhar sua
ambição a sua vontade o seu poder em
prol da sua transformação
só que naquele momento as melhorias ela
elas eram informais Até porque eu me
dividiria entre o trabalho que eu fazia
de inclusão diversidade na empresa e
influenciam cadeia de fazer com que as
empresas entenderem o que aquela empresa
entendesse a responsabilidade social
dela no nosso contexto fazer o trabalho
de mentoria e obviamente eu tinha
continuar entregando os resultados
acabei troquei de empresa e não trabalho
Espetacular nessa outra empresa que eu
passei e atualmente eu tô com o
especialista de inclusão diversidade
nesse banco
e paralelamente nas horas vagas eu tô eu
tô com o ideal o ideal é o Instituto
Black Ops II que ele saiu da Caixa Ele
nasceu mesmo formalmente estruturado
agora em 2020 junto com o Ian e mais
duas pessoas e curioso que ele saiu da
Caixa em 2020 um dos momentos que a
população negra mais precisa de ajuda
mais precisa de acesso acho que todo
mundo sabe mas a população negra foi a
mais impactadas emprego seja de fome
durante a anemia e é muito legal ver que
as pessoas que passam pelo id o que as
pessoas que entram em que as pessoas que
são infectadas pelo id
elas conseguem encontrar ali naquele
momento naquele contexto não só um
abraço mas talvez uma oportunidade de
transformação de vidro
Eu costumo dizer que é o Celso movimento
a ideia do que todo mundo que passa e
pelo que ele possa pegar tudo que ele tá
aprendendo ali mentoria palestras
contato com grandes executivos das
principais multinacionais do brasil e
aqui é importante falar de graça é um
programa de graça para pessoas negras
mais importante que as pessoas que
passam por aqui que elas voltem para
essas comunidades locais e possam
dividir que lembra que eu comecei
falando que viver é partir voltar e
repartir E aí exatamente sobre isso e
quando eu falo que não correr atrás
correr na frente é extremamente
importante para o seu desenvolvimento é
para que a gente saia desse momento e
simplesmente sobreviver e passa a viver
parceria
Se tem uma coisa que dentro da nossa
estrutura foi desenhada foi construída
para gente
é exatamente para gente continuar nesse
livro de sobreviver de ficar correndo
atrás
e o movimento é apenas uma ferramenta de
transformação seja da pessoa uma
ferramenta de transformação da sociedade
mais uma ferramenta também transformação
de lembrança
e que cada empresa ela tem uma
responsabilidade social não é só vir
aqui fazer dinheiro lucrar e voltar é
entender que aí eu não tô falando
somente de pauta de ecidir é entender
que quando a gente precisa construir uma
sociedade melhor uma sociedade mais
justa passa também pelo desenvolvimento
das pessoas eu poderei entrar no mérito
de trabalhar com a diversidade e
inclusão é importante para o negócio e
aí se você fazer um recorte para
população negra
isso é mais importante ainda até porque
40% do consumo do Brasil ele é voltado
para as pessoas negras poderia eu
poderia falar que trabalhar com
diversidade inclusão importante porque
se você não tem pessoas diversas dentro
do seu time é probabilidade de você não
performar eu não entregar ou não
refletir produtos tal qual a sociedade é
importante poderia poderia falar também
que essa ferramenta que é voltado para
pessoas precisam movimento de pessoas e
que essas pessoas vão cada vez mais
entrar dentro dessa estrutura para poder
continuar revolucionando
quando era mais novo eu não tinha essa
oportunidade eu não tive essa
oportunidade
até porque a gente vive em outro
contexto
mas quando eu olho e vejo que hoje a
gente começa a dar esses Passos esses
primeiros e segundos esse terceiro passo
e o velório acaba sendo uma ferramenta
de transformação da pessoa e
transformação social eu fico feliz
demais tô feliz demais de ver pessoas
passando pelo eBay e receber Nossa
transformação então quando eu bato na
tecla que não correr atrás porque na
frente é muito importante é importante
para pessoa é importante para gente
continue continuar nutrindo a ambição de
cada jovem negro e negra que passa em
Felipe porque eu tenho certeza
que tudo isso que a gente tá fazendo
acaba voltando então não corro atrás ou
na frente obrigado